[Music]
thank you
since August 2021 the FBI has received
reports of several packages that were
sent to U.S companies in transportation
insurance and defense
the packages came in two variants
one mimicked a message from HHS U.S
Department of Health and Human Services
with a letter inside with references to
covid-19 protection guidelines and a
flash drive with additional materials
the other imitated a package from Amazon
gift wrapped inside was a fake thank you
letter a fake gift card and a lilygo USB
flash drive
[Music]
the FBO discovered that the flash drives
were sent out by the hack group Finn 7
known for their dark side and black Mata
encryption Tools in this video we have
taken apart such a flash drive connected
it to a working computer recorded all
the changes it made to the system and we
will show you in detail how an attack
can be organized against your company or
against your family and most importantly
you'll see how to protect yourself from
this threat
this video was created by the some
sub-verification platform but more out
some stuff in a bit
oh yeah
probably wondered who this mysterious
voice is I think it's time to get
acquainted my name is Elliot and I am
your voice assistant who helps you
survive in the online jungle
well let's get back to our story it
looks like an ordinary flash drive in
fact it is the bad USB which is capable
of causing irreparable damage to your
data let's open it up
[Music]
as we can see inside there is an Arduino
Pro micro board let's take a closer look
this board clearly has but does not use
a micro USB interface and as we can see
in order not to arouse suspicion of the
victim the connector was soldered to a
classic USB plug and the board itself is
obviously not designed for soldering
full USB in this case they did the
tricky thing the plug was glued to the
case and the board was soldered with a
pair of rigid wires this was done to
force the ejection of the stick onto the
case and not onto the board
so what does this very bad flash drive
do let's check it out we have a computer
that is not connected to a network and
does not contain any important data the
flash drive does not know that we now
have a key logger running on this
computer which records all keystrokes we
will check the log of this program later
but for now let's take a look at the
computer screen
immediately after connecting the execute
window opens let's stop the recording
and look at what was written in the
startup window this command runs
malicious code from the attacker's
server for example from a rented digital
ocean virtual type there is no data on
the fake flash drive of course moreover
the behavior is clear it is not a flash
drive but in this case it's the keyboard
more precisely the device is programmed
as a keyboard this can be checked in
task manager now let's have a look at
the log what do we see
a miniature device with a keyboard
controller immediately after connection
performs random keystrokes the ability
to pre-program these keystrokes is
usually used to enter any OS command by
using the corresponding hotkeys for
example Windows r or alt F2 the most
popular form factor of such a device is
a flash drive but given the small size
of the device it can be built anywhere
whether it's a webcam or even a USB
cable OMG cable the suitable device form
is set by the context as the choice must
be optimal in one situation or another
in addition this attack requires social
engineering skills in most cases the
flash drive is essentially a decoy it is
thrown in different ways in the letter
in a parcel in a mailbox it's
accompanied by letters which convince
the victim that it's authentic and does
not arouse suspicion the main thing for
the victim is to plug the flash drive
into the computer
obviously once a flash drive attack
occurs well it can pretty trick you to
undo it it is of course a hardware
attack at the end of the day hi my name
is Luke from samsa and I'm going to tell
you a little bit about how we can
prevent some of these attacks from
occurring in the first place you know
what could lower the amount of attacks
that occur like this well by simply
verifying the address in the beginning
thumbs up is a leader in online address
verification whether it be in banking
Finance gambling or many other business
types we're able to verify the address
of someone to three main weights the
first one being document upload
basically taking in that utility bill
they're also familiar with something
that we like to call geolocation which
is essentially finding out where you are
based on a number of factors without the
document upload and the third option
would then be access to government
databases where available companies can
then Implement these methods
simultaneously or pick and choose which
parts are going to suit your business
best if you want to learn more about
some subs address verification Solutions
as well as our other products please
feel free to click the link below
and this is how the attack was
demonstrated in the TV series Mr Robot
once the flash drive is inserted into a
USB port it will execute the code filled
into it via programmed keystrokes which
will subsequently give the attacker
remote access
[Music]
connection closed by remote host
the attack is extremely fast as
keystrokes are made quite quickly it's
quite possible that the user will not
even notice anything
as a hardware part attackers sometimes
use ready-made Solutions like hack 5.
however a person who has heard at least
something about rubber ducky May suspect
Danger from the logo scattering around
dozens of such flash drives must be
cheap and widespread in fact such flash
drives must become a consumable item
it's true homemade solutions dictate
their own limitations this table shows
approximate prices for devices that can
be disguised as a flash drive and their
compatibility with operating systems as
you can see all this is extremely cheap
and available in almost any country in
the world the bigger problem is getting
the casing usually criminals buy the
cheapest flash drive of the right size
and remove the contents leaving only the
casing or they print the casing on a 3D
printer as for the software part Arduino
built-in loader supports multiple
reflashing it's at Mega 32u4 you can
write to it the commands repeatedly for
each specific situation in essence you
only need to fill it up with user
application code it's not possible to
extract such code from the flash drive
which came into our hands but we have
written a sketch that could perform all
the functions recorded in the log
now let's see what an attacker is likely
to do to gain remote access the shortest
way is to run a rat remote
Administration tool that is to install a
back door on the computer for example
windows
Linux
each of the above commands is built in
and as short as possible in one action
it downloads and runs code over HTTP or
better https
before the attack the attacker most
likely won't know what the restrictions
are on the local network so there is no
absolute guarantee of success the signal
May simply not get through but the
execution of the commands even in this
case will give the attacker enough
information first since the server
address is given by name a DNS query
will be executed the DNS system is
distributed and the query from the
victim's computer will usually be sent
anyway if the hacker is using his own
DNS Stone delegated to a subordinate
server he will see the query in the logs
this will be a signal that the flash
drive was connected and the rce has
occurred however this does not guarantee
that network access is possible
second if access to the internet is not
restricted in any way the attacker's
server will receive a HTTP request which
can also be seen in the logs this will
be a signal that a network connection is
possible and that the hacker can
remotely control the victim's computer
however this does not guarantee that the
security mechanisms of the operating
system allow the execution of the remote
control program nevertheless even if the
attack fails the attacker will have
information about the rules of access to
the internet from the user's computer
and their awareness of such incidents
such information can be used in repeat
attacks and there is an even more
terrifying type of attack that is often
overlooked an attack on a locked down
computer
imagine that someone came to your house
for a visit or broke into your apartment
when you weren't there or pretended to
be a client in your office and being
unnoticed he inserted a flash drive into
the USB input of the turned off computer
when the office system unit is pushed
into a Dusty dark corner it's easy
enough to insert something
inconspicuously there and people won't
notice anything for several years do you
often look at the back of your computer
at home
but your mouse or keyboard can be
replaced with an identical one that has
a built-in bad USB
but why do this if the computer does not
work it's simple the criminal programs
are flash drive to send keystrokes not
immediately but every n hours or minutes
to catch the moment when the machine
will be turned on and unlocked this is
called delayed rce as long as the PC is
locked all clicks will go to the
password input field and disappear I.E
the attack will go virtually unnoticed
in fact such a device makes useless all
attempts to ensure security by locking
the computer which everyone is so used
to after all once left unattended a
laptop can have such a device inserted
into it and no matter whether the
computer has been locked or not bad USB
flash drive will try to perform clicks
we mean arbitrary code at intervals of a
few minutes hours or days and sooner or
later the moment will definitely come
when the PC will be unlocked then the
malicious code will be executed and the
hacker will get remote access
and now let's talk about how to protect
yourself probably the best protection
here is to use specialized software
Solutions allowing the connection of
only pre-approved devices from the list
a whitelist each USB device has its own
unique vendor ID and product ID which
are listed on the whitelist all other
USB devices including bad USB sticks
will not be recognized by the OS this
method perfectly protects not only from
the attack described above but also from
a number of other attacks and can
generally keep working computers from a
host of undesirable consequences and the
most important rule is common sense and
caution just as children must not talk
to strangers the adults must not put any
unfamiliar devices into their computers
well you can do it only on a safe clean
computer with no important data and no
internet access if you're really curious
well some sub is always ready to help
you satisfy your curiosity safely and
win all these battles in the online
jungle
[Music]